joseph boulogne also known as the
chevalier desonjorge is perhaps the most
famous musician and composer you've
never heard of a soldier athlete musical
genius and revolutionary he was the
creme de la creme of 18th century french
society
boulogne was born in 1745
on the caribbean island of guadalupe
then part of a large french empire in
the americas his mother was an enslaved
senegalese woman called nanon his father
was georges boulogne a white plantation
owner and usually for an illegitimate
mixed heritage child bologna was given
his aristocratic father's name
georges boulogne was keen for his son to
receive a good education and he was sent
to france to be tutored in literature
and fencing as well as showing great
skill in sports
was intelligent and charismatic which
along with his father's social
connections meant he was granted access
to elite circles of french society
it didn't hurt that he was quite the
looker too
as if being handsome clever and a
champion athlete wasn't enough roulonia
was a seriously skilled musician and
composer his main instrument was the
violin and by 1761 he was made a member
of the electron don delegate the royal
guards as a soldier and musician it is
around this time that he became known as
the chevalier de santos in recognition
of his skill as a fencer and horseman
he was then invited to join the
incredibly prestigious concert des
amateur as first violinist and he became
its leader by 1773.
as a composer he specialized in a new
style called symphony concertant where
two soloists within a wider orchestra
would compete kind of like a rap battle
but with fancier instruments
by the mid-1770s roulogne was becoming
popular in paris with one publication
calling him the best composer and
musician of the kingdom
although things were going very well for
bologna he still experienced overt
racism some of the opera's leading women
petitioned queen marie antoinette
against having what they called a
mulatto in charge of the opera
despite this attempt to sabotage his
career he fell into favour with the
influential playwright madame de
montesol who put him in charge of her
private theater not as rude as it sounds
and introduced him to her fancy husband
the duke of orleans
boulonn became good friends with the
duke and was devastated when he died in
1785.
soon after he visited london where he
met other aristocrats like the chevalier
dion who was probably transgender and
prominent abolitionists such as william
wilberforce
we can't know for sure but it's likely
this trip shaped brillon's thinking
around both race and gender meanwhile
the french revolution had broken out and
heads were about to start rolling
despite his connections to the
aristocracy he sided with the
revolutionaries
he became captain in the lil national
guard then colonel of his own regiment
of soldiers which included many people
of color
as the revolution became more radical he
was rewarded
by being thrown in jail
in an atmosphere thick with suspicion
and violence between the inviting
revolutionaries mulan was imprisoned for
18 months
sadly milan died in 1799 after an ulcer
in his leg turned gangrenous aged around
53
shortly after bloom's death napoleon
seized power in france and reinstated
slavery in the french colonies
the people of guadalupe resisted around
6 000 of them were killed
napoleon also banned belongs music in an
attempt to erase him from french history
afro-caribbean communities within france
and on guadeloupe and martinique have
been working tirelessly to keep his
legacy alive and joseph brulon or the
chevalier de sanjos is now enjoying a
long overdue and richly deserved revival
bravo
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video